hello everybody we're here doing a
charity livestream for Alzheimer's
research we're raising money for the
Fisher Center for Alzheimer's research
it's one highly rated charity and we are
here in our awesome computer setup you
can see here it's pretty dang amazing
except for this that's not so amazing
and you can see here we've got our page
set up we're raising through fundraisers
so we can accept all forms of payment
including PayPal American Express and
Discover card okay anyway so we're gonna
be playing a lot of games quick three
Arena definitely left4dead to some other
miscellaneous games and of course
minecraft for warm up and warm down I
guess so please join us click the link
in the description below thank you guys
so much and we will see you there